hey guys it's the 19th so it's time for
another update on Archer engine as I do
monthly updates on the 19th or as close
to it as we can get but I've been pretty
consistent for the last few months the
only big change this month was really
that we changed the project structure is
now a cmake project this is no longer a
visual studio Windows only and I tested
compiling on Linux Mint as well as
Windows so it seems to work pretty good
there are some new instructions for uh
using they're not perfect if you want to
update them you can that's supposed to
have some data there
must have not got merged yeah there's
some uh Windows instructions the windows
side still assumes you have VC PKG
installed
to get the libraries but it should just
work automatically as long as you've got
it installed which is pretty simple you
basically just go clone it and you do a
bootstrap and then that's pretty much it
um but look at their instructions for
Linux all you got to do is uh basically
I have to get this whole line of stuff
which is just required libraries and
then you can just build it um you use
cmake but I made a little Linux build
thing to Auto handle it and then you can
run the fpp demo drag in a model and fly
around and look at it
Windows is the same thing now I've
noticed there's some Shader error on
Linux at least on my machine it might be
my video card but things look a little
weird on Linux but it runs fine so
yeah that's uh that's basically where it
is now do you guys want to see a run of
it cool I'll show you
so we're just going to open up our
command line go to our e Drive actually
it's our D drive and then uh Source
Archer oh it didn't switch Drive
there we go no change directory needed
for that one we should be able to just
go cmax go out build has the folder and
the sources here doesn't recognize it
because I don't have cmake installed and
added to my app okay well it's all set
up through Visual Studio all you got to
do is uh continue without code go to
file open cmake and navigate your path
find your top level C make and open it
and visual studio just has cmake
installed as some kind of extension I
suppose I'm not actually entirely sure
but uh it will handle all running all
the commands for you and it'll generate
a little config for you and stuff like
that so just an IDE that can be handy so
we're on the Windows cmake branch and I
am going to well
there's only one executable in here
right now and that's this fpp demo but
this also requires the library to be
built which is uh the top level main
project
and it's all these files which I've
lazily done glob recurse on everything
I know I know
don't at me
but then we just add the library right
there and uh the example is that fpp
more examples to come if you're welcome
to you know anyone's welcome to hack on
this you want to add examples fix the
test there's a lot of stuff to be done
in case that isn't obvious but you know
one thing at a time I think this next
month planning on focusing on some
Dynamic shaders and improving those and
we might pop in a different render
because opengl is fine but I want to
play around with some other stuff too
anyway that's the top level C make let's
just run this demo and I'll drag in a
model so I'm just gonna find a random
model on my machine I've got a bunch in
here that I've saved over time oh
there's the window it says editor it's
not a true editor sure I'd like to turn
it into one but I haven't even put I
should put like a little interface in
here it'd actually be easy with I'm GUI
or something just like a file menu or
you could go open and do some stuff you
know there's a lot of uh things I need
done on this editor obviously anyway I'm
going to bring in this uh I guess this
rifle as an obj
and there it is and we should be able to
fly around it uh right click gets you in
and out of the first person control mode
okay
and uh you know yeah it'd be cool we
could turn this into a little editor
start putting the interface stuff in
here the old ad Skybox all the little
tools to edit things yeah it would
basically just be a forwarding operation
because all those functions are still in
source
or uh well the function definitions are
going to include interface
so that's basically everything you can
do with the engine is right here but I'm
rambling on so that's all I really did
was get it working with CMA the tests
haven't been forwarded yeah they used to
work on Windows but I need to uh change
that to a more Universal system so the
code's all there just haven't even put a
cmake list on there and edited things to
get it working but I'm probably I don't
I don't know how much spend time I'm
going to spend on this it's next month
if I do I'm just going to be toying
around with some things that I think
maybe I talked about already a little
Shader stuff maybe some interface get
the unit test going which is all it's
all up in there if anyone's watching
this and thinks uh you know I'd like to
hack on that a little bit feel free the
code's up on GitHub
um
yeah it's just a free and open project
that I'm gonna try my best to keep that
way as long as we don't run into any
issues with it I I don't know why we
would but just trying to think out loud
well anyway I've also been uh messing
with Unreal Engine a lot so I've been uh
kind of messing with animations learning
more about animation so I will show you
some of that uh basically I've got some
builds of one kind of sample I was
working on and I got seven different
versions so I got I've worked on it for
basically seven eight days straight and
uh version zero was the first
initialization of it so let's look at
that it's gonna be terrible don't worry
it's it was it was day one a knit of the
project looked like this uh okay there
it is so you can see we got some basic
movement in and we got a sun that uh
kind of Cascades or whatever a little
day night cycle all right let's jump
forward a few versions to version three
it's kind of making some daily
improvements learning some stuff I think
I might have imported this SWAT guy Yep
this guy from miximo tried to mess with
my own set of animations to see how I
could get them to look and I was feeling
kind of okay there were some Oddities
here and there but overall it was mostly
okay the uh
crouching needed some work but you can
see we are in a new terrain we'll sample
terrain and still a day night cycle just
kind of tweaking this date cycle a lot
it gets a little too dark maybe but
whatever it's just a demo
so let's uh let's go to the last version
here's where it was when I left off in
this oh never mind we never got that
build I guess we got version six
never version seven never built well
anyway the project had a bit of an error
I was trying to use some uh Version
Control stuff and I accidentally removed
all my model and animation files somehow
so the Project's still there and just
chilling but uh it needs all the models
re-imported and it should work again but
also it's not that big of a deal I can
recreate this amount of movement in this
daylight cycle it was pretty simple it
was a great learning experience but I
kind of got the Crouch worked out tried
to get the night and day working a
little better this is kind of a fast
cycle here and I also put a light on the
player it doesn't cast shadows and I
thought it looked okay we can do all the
things you would want to do and there's
really no major glitches in the movement
so I was pretty happy with the movement
at this point but I think I did still
improve a few other things and if it was
day all the time I could be sampling it
more but it keeps going tonight because
I have the day night cycle really fast
on this build but anyway
um there's also you're kind of locked
into this initial area and I was maybe
be gonna put some initial gameplay here
or something that was kind of the idea
and then you can go well beyond further
into the terrain later so it was
actually a pretty big kind of open World
style map going on here but I don't
really know what the gameplay was going
to be it was going to make a little
story kind of skyrim-esque random I
don't know bsre I didn't really have an
exact idea but that was where I would go
next if uh I went with it maybe copy
some stuff from a DND campaign that
happened once or something like that
that's always fun
so that's what I spent most of my time
messing with I uh have a new project
I've been working on called Mandan it's
it's nothing it's just a throwaway
project but I've been once again messing
with movement adding some attacks some
kicks and some Landing animations and
kind of trying to make it look a little
better but uh ultimately just another
throwaway project and you can see this
is another model from miximo I wanted to
really learn and understand their
animation system and
it's way harder than you would think
there's a lot to it there's quite a few
options here in unreal I've been using
the animation States for the most part
and go on from there and just making a
state machine all these variables for if
you're moving and how you're moving and
it feels weird I I feel like there's got
to be a better way but there is some
pretty cool stuff I've learned along the
way like you can make these functions
and you can call these functions in any
of these so once I figured that out I
kind of learned how to make the
animations play as long as I wanted and
that sort of stuff and put variables
around these functions but it becomes
kind of code spaghetti after a while it
felt like so I uh I don't know what I'm
gonna do from here but I plan on
researching the animation and stuff with
unreal a lot more in my spare time and
we'll see where this goes if you want
builds of these games I'm gonna post
them somewhere on my patreon so patrons
can have access to these as they come
out there of course no you know they're
not releases they're just little samples
of it I might as well do something with
them and I can at least do that
well there's also another slot on the
patreon for uh tutoring and stuff
basically just meeting with me once a
month for an hour
there's one more slot available so
uh whoever wants that cool all right
well I will see you guys in the next
video peace out